what is up and welcome to your ninth WX
Python tutorial video in this video
we're going to be talking about sub
menus and toolbar additions basically
and if you don't know what a sub menu is
it's kind of like when you go to like
file open recent or something like that
then it like lists out some stuff that's
kind of what a sub menu is if you still
don't know what a sub menu is well then
just follow along and you're going to
learn what a sub menu is so we're going
to put this right above exit item and
below this edit button and basically
here we're going to define the button
so we'll say it's an import item is a
the item equals WX and it's a menu item
then we're going to say import item dot
append so we're going to append to this
and it's ID it will just be like any
social so random button and then the
title or what we want this button to say
we'll say import a document right and
just for the sake of it let's add a
couple more so it's clearly a list and
then here we'll just say picture and
then here we'll say video next what
we're going to want to do is append this
to our file button so we want to be able
to go file import right so the next
thing we want to do is file button dot
append menu and where again it's WX and
we'll just do ID any
II and then what's the title of the like
that submenu that we want to be and
that's going to be import and then what
is the actual button itself that's
import item close off the parenthesis
there and that should be it will save it
will run it go through our three things
here and here is our window welcome
Harrison some awesome text that we've
made man we are making a ballin program
so now when you go to file about quit
and now we've also got import and then
we've got other things that we can do
like we can import a document a picture
or a video now it's just a button it
won't do anything if you click it well
click it it's not going to do anything I
might even error for us in a little bit
and so it it's not doing anything yet
but you can start to do event handlers
just like we do when we quit so that's a
submenu and the next thing that we're
going to cover is just briefly the tool
bar so to do that you'll come below here
and we'll define our tool bar and the
tool bar is going to be self die create
tool bar now create toolbar is a WX
Python built-in function so now we're
going to do let's add a quit button to
the toolbar so we'll add a quit tool
button equals a toolbar die and label
tool and in here it's going to just be
WX we'll just do ID any and the name of
this will be quit and and that's really
just I that will appear on your status
bar if you have it and then W X dot
bitmap and now we just need a bitmap
image and central run out of space let's
just continue down here W X dot bitmap
and we'll do tool quit PNG close close
and then you'll have to do a pull-up one
more here you'll need to do tool bar dot
realize again realizes WX python
function then all that's going to do is
put the toolbar there right or the image
of it there so here is my quit button
that I made now that's there but it
doesn't do anything we can quickly pair
click the heck out of it nothing happens
so now we need to make it do what our
other quit button does so to do that we
need to do cell top bond and to that
we're going to bind a WX event tool
that's going to do self dot quit now
quit is not built-in I'll show you that
in just a second and then we're going to
apply this to quit tool button which we
made up here now self dot quit does old
man's wait on this right it's going to
do this quit function so like later on
when you do like an import if you wanted
to you could do font put you could
define import stuff and then you could
start you know put your parameters and
then you start defining what happens
when someone clicks it so just like you
can define this quit function same thing
like what to do when you go to import so
now when we say this we'll run this and
here's our window you hit quit and it
quits so pretty basic stuff um I'm just
going to show you adding one more item
to the toolbar since it kind of helps to
see like because that's you're going to
have multiple things so at least for me
it helps me learn when like if I learn
to apply like many times and stuff and
see like what okay if you want two of
these what needs to change because you
don't need to realize the toolbar twice
you don't have to create the toolbar
twice etc so anyway next thing we're
going to do is we're going to do an
import tool button that's going to equal
a toolbar and I bet you can guess what's
coming
yep ad label add label to and I bet you
can guess what's coming first in the
parameters yeah ie any and this we're
going to call import and we'll come down
here for some more params and this is
can you guess it big map but I bet you
can't guess the file name cuz you don't
know it I hope I hope nobody can guess
it actually it's not too bad to guess
import PNG save it run it and we'll just
run through this and wow look at these
awesome buttons by the way you can hire
me for graphic design I charge about two
hundred dollars an hour but you can get
really high quality buttons from me so
just let me know and so now that we've
got we got quit you can quit here and
you can import here but like for quick
stuff that you want to be able to do
like quit and then you can also do some
imports but again we have no handler for
the import like right now it's just a
button you click it and nothing happens
whereas in the future you'll want to say
like self dot import and then you'll
have an import function it's going to do
all this cool stuff but for now it's
just a little button there and I'm just
showing you guys how to use it and just
like everything else like you can resize
it and stuff so anyway hopefully you
guys have been good enjoying these
tutorials as always thanks for watching
and thank you for subscribing